Чи не перед кожними виборами українцям обіцяють
знизити тарифи на комунальні послуги.
Це улюблена популістична тема політиків
для швидкого завоювання голосів.
Але очікувати суттєвого зниження тарифів не варто.
Ось деякі з головних причин.
В Україні 25 обленерго,
які надають електроенергію населенню і підприємствам.
Майже всі вони вже давно виведені з-під контролю держави
і перебувають у власності олігархів –
Ріната Ахметова, Ігоря Коломойського, Костянтина Григоришина тощо.
Це робилося під приводом того, що у приватних руках
підприємства працюватимуть ефективніше.
Втім, саме ці, вже приватні обленерго, постійно мотивують державу
піднімати тарифи, мовляв, для модернізації старих мереж.
Однак розслідування українських журналістів показують,
що обленерго часто завищують свої витрати
та купують нове устаткування у споріднених компаній.
За цією схемою власники обленерго
показують масштабні витрати, а за поповненням грошового балансу
фактично звертаються до кишені громадян.
Тарифи на опалення залежать від рівняенергоефективності
того чи іншого будинку, оскільки мешканці платять
не лише за фактично використане тепло, а й за енерговтрати.
В Україні близько 90% старих багатоповерхівок
вже давно час модернізувати, вважають фахівці.
Більшість з них побудували за часів, коли про енергоефективність мало хто замислювався.
Зекономити вдвічі мешканці цих будинків можуть,
лише якщо приміром, утеплять його повністю.
Менше платять мешканці нових будинків,
які, по-перше, зведені здебільшого із застосуванням енергозберігаючих технологій,
а по-друге, оснащені квартирними лічильниками.
Про можливість знизити ціну на газ за рахунок власного видобутку
говорив вже не один політик.
Як аргумент наводився той факт, що населення споживає16 мільярдів кубів газу
і фактично стільки ж становить власний видобуток України.
Однак це загальний видобуток газу в державному секторі.
Тобто результат роботи трьох компаній –
"Укргазвидобування", "Укрнафти" та "Чорноморнафтогазу".
Втім, згідно із постановою Кабміну,
газ для населення постачає лише "Укргазвидобування".
Ця компанія, приміром, у 2017 році
видобула для потреб населення близько 14 мільярдів кубів газу,
тобто майже на 2 мільярди менше, ніж було потрібно.
Тож, Україна добуває недостатньо газу для своїх потреб,
і без імпорту поки не обійтися.
Окрім того, коли ціни для населення низькі,
а для промисловості вищі, ринкові,
то відкривається шлях до корупційних схем.
Замість популістичних обіцянок про зниження комунальних тарифів,
варто було б принаймні не перешкоджати українцям
заощаджувати завдяки зеленому тарифу, вважають експерти.
НатомістьВерховна Рада нещодавно заборонила будівництво
домашніх сонячних електростанцій на землі,
вмотивувавши це тим, що українці встановлюють станції не для власних потреб,
а щоб продавати енергію за завищеною вартістю.
А це, мовляв, могло б призвести
до подорожчання ціни на електроенергію вчетверо.
Втім, домашні сонячні електростанції наразі мають
мізерну частку на енергоринку України – лише 6% від усіх "зелених".
Збільшення вироблення електроенергії домашніми СЕС
прямо не впливає на вартість електроенергії для побутових споживачів.
Адже в об’єднаній енергетичній системі України
діє єдина система тарифів, яку встановлює профільна Нацкомісія.